all right here's something a little bit
of a
of a lighter note or maybe not so much
lighter uh back in 1963 some daily wire
Elizabeth Taylor then the hottest
actress in the world starred as
Cleopatra in an over-the-top start a
studded Blockbuster with a 31 million
dollar budget equal to 327 million
dollars in today's dollars
Taylor likely didn't look much like the
Egyptian queen what with her Lily white
skin and dark blue eyes with purple
irises but back then everything wasn't
so politically correct and people didn't
take offense at meaningless things skip
ahead 60 years Netflix's new documentary
Queen Cleopatra has drawn controversy
and black washing claims after Adele
James a black actress was cast in a lead
role as Cleopatra and yes in fact
historical records show the clear
Cleopatra was not black but Macedonian
Greek
the documentary part of the African
queen series explores the rise and fall
of the last pharaoh of Egypt and was
released on May 10th but it's the Dismal
ratings that are making headlines the
documentary currently has a two percent
audience rating on Rotten Tomatoes which
Forbes says it's the is the lowest in
history
the average Tomato Meter score which
calculates how many critics rate it
favorably stands at 10 percent
so it is a 10 rating among the critics
and a two percent rating among the
actual uh you know regular audience
um here's how bad it is the worst film
on the movie rating site ballistic X
versus sever in 2002 has a zero percent
rating on the Tomato Meter but a 20
favorable rating by the audience
another stinker One Missed Call from
2008 also has a zero percent Tomato
Meter but a twenty percent audience
score and the Nicholas Cage bomb Left
Behind from 2014 got zero percent from
the critics but 22 from the audience
whereas this only has two percent from
the audience
Forbes notes that the creator of the
series Tina Garvey has defended the
casting Choice she said quote why
shouldn't Cleopatra be a melanated
sister and why do some people need
Cleopatra to be white her proximity to
whiteness seems to give her value and
for some Egyptians it seems to really
matter after much hand ringing and
countless auditions we found in Adele
James an actor who could convey not only
Cleopatra's Beauty but also her strength
what the historians can confirm is that
it is more likely that Cleopatra looked
like Adele than Elizabeth Taylor ever
did ever did summer is here and good
ranchers wants to give you what you've
been craving which is a nice summer
steak on the grill can you hear the
sizzle already I know that I can I'm not
sure what your favorite steak is but
mine is every steak I get from good
ranchers they're all great every cut is
Source from local American Farms and
hand cut trimmed and aged to Perfection
they have rib eyes New York strips all
natural burgers and all the most
delicious chicken you could ever want
plus it's 30 off with my code wall
should goodranchers.com good ranchers is
committed to giving you inflation-proof
meat that you can count on right now
they're offering a price lock guarantee
for the next two years and uh there's
never been a better time to take
advantage of an offer like that imagine
if you could if you could have locked in
your price two years ago you would have
saved hundreds well don't wait any
longer gear up for an unforgettable
summer of barbecues and everything else
all the delicious food that you want
great company and the perfect Ambiance
thanks to our friends at good ranchers
head to goodranchers.com and use my code
Walsh for 30 off any box delicious
American Meat and 30 off your order you
can't beat that that's promo code wall
should goodranchors.com goodrancers.com
American Meat delivered pro-life battle
has finally left to DC and it's going to
the Grassroots as one of the largest
pro-life organizations in the world no
one's in a better position than 40 Days
for life to end abortion in a post-row
America with uh one million Volunteers
in 1500 cities 40 Days for life holds
peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities because of that they actually
have a larger presence in blue States
especially California former abortion
clinic directors say that these vigils
can cause the abortion no-show rate to
go as high as 75 percent which is
disastrous for their business and thank
God for that these law-abiding visuals
have helped close abortion facilities in
San Francisco Seattle and Chicago many
other cities as well they also are
leading the way in efforts to prevent
pharmacies from dispensing chemical
abortions you can support their work and
check out their locations podcast and
free magazine at 40 daysforlife.com the
pro-life Fight Continues it's never been
more important and for more information
on 40 Days for Life go to
40daysforlife.com
you know
here's the thing about this I'm um
I could be perfectly fine with the race
swapping of his of of certainly race
swapping of fictional characters I could
be completely fine with that
and even with historical figures I could
be fine with that too
you know a different take a different
interpretation on historical figure
um any any biopic um even something that
builds itself as a documentary as this
does but but all these films they all
they all fictionalize the lives of these
historical figures to some degree and so
I could be okay with a version of a
story where they swap the race out and
they take a a white historical figure
and have a black actor actress portray
them I could be totally fine with that
if
we had a consistent standard for these
sorts of things
okay if if we just took the approach
across the board that hey you know
whatever whichever actor you know seems
to nail the role the best
just cast them it doesn't really matter
what their race is and there's a little
bit of suspension of disbelief but again
you know all these stories are these are
either fictional stories or at a minimum
they are fiction fictionalized accounts
of historical events and so it doesn't
you know the race doesn't matter
if that was our attitude
across the board then I'd be fine with
that I'd be on board with that
but we know that's not the case
um
we know that uh this would never go the
other way it never could go the other
way
you certainly would not find Netflix
putting out a documentary about a black
an actual black historical figure being
portrayed by a white person that would
never happen
but if there is any hope of compromise
if this is one issue we can compromise
on I'd take that compromise
race swapping you know have fun with it
do everything you want you want to put
out a biopic about Martin Luther King Jr
and and actually have
um someone like Ryan Gosling betray him
go ahead and do it
that would uh you know it would make for
some interesting films at least
but they want to take one standard and
uh and apply it you know inconsistently
to one group of people and uh and that
just doesn't work you can't it's you
can't do that we're going to hold you by
your own standards but that's the point
that it is on the left this is your
standard
it's not that we really care that much
about race swapping it's not it's not
our issue
you care about it and so we are holding
you to your own standard we know we
can't we can't depend on you to do that
this can't be an honor System sort of
thing so we have to force you to stand
by your own standard
and I'll do it for this portion shows
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed